[Music]
hello and welcome to
statey ridge on sunday what would we
have thought
a year ago if we'd been told the
government was considering allowing us
to sit on a park bench with one person
from another household
and that this would be front page news
like a lot of the last things
in the last 12 months it would have felt
pretty surreal but that's where we are
as we wait for clarity from the
government about how lockdown will be
eased
to be fair it's only one part of the
speculation floating around there's big
questions about
schools shops and hospitality as well
and today we'll be trying to get some
answers
we've got just the lineup for it in a
moment we'll be joined by the foreign
secretary
dominic raab the first minister of wales
mark drakeford will be on the programme
today as well professor tim spector from
king's college london who runs a leading
study tracking the progress
of kovic 19 in an app the shadow chief
secretary to the treasury bridget
phillipson will be looking ahead to the
budget
and as she prepares to step down as
children's commissioner for england
we'll also be hearing from ann longfield
but first the government set a target to
offer a first vaccine to all over 70s
nhs and care workers
and care home residents by tomorrow so
will they meet that target well let's
ask a man who should hopefully know the
foreign secretary
dominic graham thank you for being on
the programme this morning good morning
so the government's target is to
vaccinate the top four priority groups
by
tomorrow are you going to meet the
target
well there's been huge progress made and
we're confident we're on track to do so
we'll obviously get the final data
um later on today and tomorrow and it
will be a really important milestone
because
that's the top four priority groups that
have been offered the first
dose and it is the if you like the first
milestone towards the wider plan to get
99 of those at risk of dying vaccinated
with the first dose by the end of april
and then everyone in the country uh
every adult in the country offered a
first dose by
the autumn and that's part of the road
maps so uh
the nhs teams i was down at my local
vaccination center in walton
the volunteers there uh nadim zahawi
mahakal
a great job but of course this is only
the
first step in the vaccination rollout
it's going well but we've got to keep it
up
you must know if you're going to meet
the target by tomorrow are you just
leaving it for your boss to announce
well i'm confident we're on track to do
so
uh they the the numbers look good but i
want to wait until we've got
the formally published uh figures so
that we're doing it accurately and and
in the right way so
i can't quite jump the gun uh but i can
tell you that we're on track and we're
confident that we will
meet that target and of course the
target was uh come
come monday so come tomorrow so uh
you'll get the full
data then but it's a really important
first step in the vaccine rollout
and we then evaluate all of the data and
the prime minister on the 22nd of
february so monday we will set out the
plans going forward
because of course we understand people
want to know a bit more
what the next stage would involve they
want that light at the end of the tunnel
and it's right that we do it this way
based on the evidence
and so far the evidence is is positive
pretty clear that you're confident the
vaccine rollout is going well
so far now on friday the prime minister
is going to be hosting this virtual
g7 meeting he's going to call for
further international cooperation on
vaccine distribution
saying that governments have a
responsibility to work together
to put those vaccines to the best
possible use
so does that mean that we are planning
to give
some of our vaccines to other countries
and if so when would we do that at what
point
would we do that and who would we
prioritize
of course we're not going to do anything
that would undermine the integrity of
the domestic rollout that would be
counterproductive
and it's fair to say we have already
contributed on the international track
so these aren't binary choices we've
uh contributed uh over half a billion
pounds that will secure
uh over a billion doses through what's
called the kovacs
amc facility so we're already just to
jump in sorry you say that you wouldn't
do anything to undermine the domestic
rollout so what does that actually mean
does that mean you're not going to give
any vaccines away until
every adult in the uk's received their
first days what does that mean
so first of all we are already
supporting and indeed
leading the way with our g7 presidency
of the international
approach we've contributed enough money
to produce
a one billion of those doses and what we
want to do is having led the way
encourage and cajole and use our
convening power to get other countries
to match that that's the way we deal
with
the global challenge that we all face i
think the the answer question is would
we
use any surplus uh vaccines from the
450 million doses that we've got for the
domestic rollout
we would need to before we start looking
at that we'll need to know
with confidence that we're able to roll
out
reliably according to the time scales
that we've got
so but these things go in parallel um
we're leading the way i think
domestically with our rollout but also
internationally
and so what the prime minister is doing
is making sure with that
strong example that we're setting we can
also encourage others to make sure that
the vulnerable countries the poorest
countries around the world
are also able to benefit from equitable
distribution of the vaccine
we need a global solution to what is a
global pandemic
okay um now let's talk a bit about the
light at the end of the tunnel that you
mentioned cases are dropping uh it seems
like you're on course to meet the
targets
uh tomorrow on vaccines now the
government wants to
reopen schools from the 8th of march
what i want to know is are you planning
on reopening
all schools to all pupils at the same
time
or are you considering a staggered
approach where for example primary
schools might go
back first or some pupils in exam year
groups might go back first
yes a good question and i know there'll
be many teachers and parents that want
uh to know those answers which is why
with the approach we've taken we've
always said that on the 22nd of february
so monday
week the prime minister will review all
the evidence
the impact of the lockdown the impact of
the vaccine
on the transmission rate and the number
of people going into hospitals with
coronavirus
will then set out the forward look but
you're absolutely right on the 8th of
march we are
aiming we are hoping to get schools back
the precise details
we need to just make sure we set out
once we've uh
evaluated all of that evidence so the
prime minister will give more of a steer
on the 22nd but the aim is to get
schools reopening in a responsible way
on the 8th
so is is the answer then you haven't
decided yet whether that's going to be
all schools
or some schools that's dependent on the
data yeah i think we need to wait
to evaluate the data carefully and allow
those plans to be put in place and of
course
the consultation goes into them uh
because i know that's important for the
stakeholders for the schools
uh and others and then the prime
minister uh on monday week will be able
to set out the full detail
but because we're making progress i
think we can feel confident that we will
be able to
uh start that process of getting schools
open on the eighth and
of course there'll be other measures
that the prime minister wants to set out
but it'll be based on the evidence and
the success that we've had
on in terms of rolling out the vaccine
and the impact that has
not just on reducing the number of cases
um but also reducing the pressure on the
nhs
okay now the sunday times on sunday
telegraph are both reporting
that at the same time there could be
some
minor relaxation of other rules the
government could announce they say
that adults will be allowed to sit down
outside on a park bench
with one friend so is it really against
the rules right now for you to sit down
on a park bench with one other person is
matt hancock going to be you know
patrolling parks and slapping you with a
10-year jail sentence if he finds you
you're not going to get a 10-year jail
sentence for a minor mistake on a park
bench but it is absolutely right that
until we change the rules
we need full compliance because that's
the way we make the
the progress that i've described i can't
tell you all the changes that will be
made
um because that's the point of having
this review
point on the 22nd of february and but
what our priority will be is schools as
a
as i mentioned i think also um it's fair
to say getting
non-essential retail open is going to be
very important and we also
i mean you mentioned things like the
ability to socialize uh
with people outside these things are
quality of life issues they really
matter
and so they're not small things we
understand i appreciate that i'm sure
everyone watching the show does but we
do need to be very careful in how we
proceed we've made good progress
we don't want to see that unravel
because we go too far too quick
as you say you know these aren't small
things there there is a serious point to
the question you know if you're
elderly or you're pregnant going for a
walk your piece of exercise
with one person from another household
which is legal and if you sit down on a
park bench for a moment
is that unlawful are you breaking the
rules
well i think the rules are pretty clear
that the the idea is not to have people
socializing but to follow the very clear
guidance for outdoor
uh activity which is can you sit down on
a park bench to maintain but it all
depends on the context and
in truth of course the media will pick
up on the old story here and there
but the police have done an incredible
job in applying
rigor but also some common sense so no
one wants to pick up people that
inadvertently find themselves a split
second in the wrong place but we do want
to make sure people aren't flouting the
rules
that is how we get back control of the
virus
that's what we have the data shows that
we're achieving
we don't want to see um that unraveling
so it so it isn't
it is important but i think we can trust
the police uh
in their interactions with the public to
get that balance right overwhelmingly
they have uh over the course of this
pandemic
okay now a group of your conservative
colleagues have written to the prime
minister they say
there's no justification for any
restrictions to remain beyond the end of
april because by then all nine priority
groups should have been given a vaccine
dose
and those groups of course represent 99
percent of covert deaths around 80
percent of hospitalizations
are they wrong well that's our a that's
the roadmap to get 99 percent of those
who are at risk of dying from this
uh the road map to ease all restrictions
by the end of april
that's not the plan though is that no
you're you're i'm putting words in my
mouth
and the plan is to get the 99 of people
at risk of dying
dispense their first dose by the end of
april certainly offered their first dose
and by doing so and taking the fatality
out of this
uh virus we are in a much better
position to proceed to start to ease the
um the lock down and we've just talked
about the way we're going to do it
starting with schools non-sexual
retail i don't think you can set though
an arbitrary target and not be
evidence-led
which is why the review point on the
22nd of february is so important we can
see the success
we've made and as you rightly point out
the we we look on course to hit the
first milestone tomorrow
then there is by the end of april to
have a further 70
million people uh offered their first
dose and we want every adult
offered their first dose by september
that's the roadmap we've set out we need
to be evidence-based
in analyzing our progress towards it but
they're saying that if
those people are vaccinated all nine
priority groups
then restrictions should end do you
agree with that or not
we're not taking a uh what what feels to
me slightly
arbitrary uh commitment without
reviewing
the impact the measures have had on the
transmission and the hospital admissions
of the virus so in that sense we're
making sure that as we go and we take
the
the steps both on the vaccine but then
in due course as we open up schools of
course
we want to see what impact that has on
the virus and we need to retain some
flexibility to deal with the variance
uh which of course are part and parcel
of dealing with the pandemic but do
alter
the precise time frame so we'll be
evidence-led but we share the
the ambition to get out of a lockdown to
transition to a better place for
economic reasons for jobs for
livelihoods
for the most vulnerable in our society
and for everyone's mental health
and professor neil ferguson this week of
imperial college told me that some
low-level restrictions face mask
wearing could even go into next year do
you think that's realistic
i just don't want to jump the gun on the
series of
uh measures that the prime minister will
announce and the roadmap
all of these things will be looked at in
the round okay now from tomorrow
arrivals from certain countries will
have to go into hotel quarantine so
how many hotels are currently signed up
and how many rooms has the government
booked
oh i don't know the precise number of
rooms booked but you're right to say
there are 33 countries in the high risk
the red list if you like
uh particularly from south america and
from africa
and in relation to british nationals
coming home
so you wouldn't be able to if you're a
foreign national coming from those
countries you won't be able to
uh come back with there's a bar on uh
entry into the uk but if you're a
british national
resident trying to get back home we will
have a system of uh
government commissioned uh uh hotel
based
quarantine for the ten days subject to
two tests and a lot of preparations gone
into that
to make sure and it's only one
additional measure if you like one extra
safeguard in the lines of defense that
we've got against new variants coming in
but i do think it's significant and
important
on top of the other border-based
restrictions we've now put in place
the times reported yesterday that so far
only 16
hotels have signed up none of them north
of birmingham and that we could run out
of rooms by thursday because there's
only 5 000 booked
and we're expecting 1 400 arrival today
so
i understand you're probably not across
the detail of exactly how many rooms but
are we going to have enough
i think we will and of course i mean the
truth is the the the travelers
largely uh dried up in any event but
what this measure allows
is uh uh 1 400 arrivals a day is quite a
lot still isn't it
nowhere near compact comparison to the
kind of travel i mean
when if you look at heathrow um airport
or any of our airports
uh that they're they're empty compared
to what we've seen previously
but we do need to make sure we've got is
a safe
reliable workable system for uk
nationals from
those uh 33 high risk countries so that
we don't find
unwittingly uh or otherwise that the
progress made
in terms of the vaccine and control of
the virus is undermined and those plans
are now being properly implemented
uh we've taken our time to get them
right and they'll be we'll be able to
deliver them from monday
you talk there about 33 countries being
on the red list but of course there are
other countries where the south africa
variant the variant of concern
has been found austria for example the
austrian region of tyrell went to
lockdown on tuesday
after 293 cases at the south africa
variant were concerned
austria is not on the list isn't it not
time to have a blanket ban
i'm not sure that's proportionate and of
course
having blanket bands on any for example
uh air travel into the uk would be very
difficult for the supply chains
things like freight which sometimes come
in you can exempt freight you can accept
freight can't you that's what france has
done
well there are different ways of looking
at we assess
the data very carefully so whenever uh
there is an outbreak or a deterioration
in one another country look at it very
carefully
um and we what we want to make sure is
we've got as targeted measure as
possible
to keep those supply chains open to make
sure british nationals or residents can
come back from abroad
but also to avoid undermining the
progress we've made
and we think we've got the right balance
robust measures but targeted measures
okay do we know how many cases of the
south africa variant there are currently
in the uk
i don't have that data i'm not sure it's
ascertainable and of course
people refer to it as the south african
variant
actually the south africans have a bit
more advanced in many other countries
in the genomic testing so the question
is where the variant first
uh is tracked um and we've of course had
a similar issue we
we're world leaders in genomic testing
and we're very transparent about things
um so like the south african so the
truth is these variants as in the course
of any pandemic
and any virus happen um and the point is
that
we've got the measures in place the
tracking the expertise in genomic
sequencing
and the international collaboration the
cooperation you have with countries
around the world
to make sure we can track it very
carefully and take proportionate
measures
now i just want to finish by asking you
about ann sakulis the american woman
involved in the 2019 crash that killed
the teenager
harry dunn now she claimed diplomatic
community returned to the us they've
since
refused to extradite her now ten days
ago her bastard told a u.s court that
she was employed by an intelligence
agency in the u.s
at the time of the crash which was
especially a factor in her departure
from
the uk now this matters because if she
was employed herself she wouldn't have
had
diplomatic immunity so when did you or
the prime minister first become aware
that ann sirkulis was employed by an
intelligence agency
at the time of the crash yeah well look
first of all we don't um comment on
intelligence matters but what i can tell
you
categorically because it's not quite
right what you've said is at the time
that ann sekules was in the uk and the
basis
of her immunity was as the uh
partner of an officer at the embassy um
and and that was the basis for it
um and we obviously sought wave of
immunity
and we've sought her return under
extradition
and we continue to do so and of course
i've raised it with the new
u.s secretary of state um we want to see
justice for
the family of harry dan and we do
believe that dan secular should be
done so did the u.s not tell you
that she was employed by the u.s
intelligence agencies at the
time of the crash as her lawyer has said
well sophie as i said first of all we
don't comment on intelligence matters
but what i can tell you categorically
is that her status was uh as the partner
the spouse
of an officer of the embassy and that
was the way both the us with us and
approach things in the way we did and
the other speculation had no impact and
wouldn't have had
any uh any uh effect on the status that
she had in the uk
so you know it now we all know it now
because it's been widely reported
when did you first find out that she was
employed by the u.s intelligence
services
so sophie you can ask me the questions
many times you like i don't comment
and uh pass comment on intelligence
matters at all
but what i can say categorically when
we've been clear with the
the family as well about this is that
her status was very clear and it was
based
on her being the the wife of an officer
of the embassy up at crouton so that was
the basis on which
she had immunity we of course wanted it
waived we of course wanted
her to be returned after she left and
that remains our position
so can you guarantee that you didn't
know that she was employed by
intelligence agency before
she left for the u.s so i can guarantee
that i don't comment on intelligence
matters as many times as people still
ask me
okay uh dominic rob thank you for coming
on the program today much appreciated
good to talk to you
dominic rob uh there he did sound quite
confident that we're on track to meet
that target to offer a vaccine to the
top four priority groups by tomorrow now
the first part of the uk to meet that
target was wales and the country's first
minister mark drakeford joins us now
thank you for being on the program this
morning mr drakeford
so congratulations on meeting the target
how did you do it so fast
well i think it's the all the credit is
due to those frontline
workers in our health service uh their
partners
in the armed forces all local
authorities the volunteers
uh it's the efforts that they have made
in every part of wales that
allowed us to get to the first target by
the end of friday and mopping up the
small numbers of people
who may have missed out the first time
they were invited for a vaccination over
this weekend
okay now we talked a bit with dominic
raag about the
idea of this hotel quarantine uh
travelers coming back from hotels in the
red list if you like of countries will
have to self-isolate in a hotel
how many quarantine hotels are there in
wales there won't be any
in wales at this point because we don't
have any flights coming
into wales from those red countries
and but we don't have any flights coming
in from abroad at all and moved to until
march and people coming through the
ports into wales are covered by the
common travel area
so scotland and england both will have
ports of entry covered by the
quarantine uh in hotels arrangement
but at this time and for several weeks
to come that will not affect us here in
wales
when you've been quite critical haven't
you the government's approach to
quarantine of course there may not be
direct flights to wales but people
entering the country
it clearly affects all of ours do you
think there needs to be more than 33
countries on the red list where you have
to quarantine if you return from there
well i would have done it in the
opposite way to the uk government
their approach is to say that everybody
can come in
other than the people on the red list i
would have said nobody can come in
other than a list of countries where we
are absolutely sure
that it is safe for people to come
without the sort of quarantine
arrangements that are being
suggested i just feel that we need to
build the wall higher
to make sure that we are not vulnerable
to new variants that could appear in any
part
of the world you know one appeared here
in this country
there's now spread elsewhere so my own
view has been
that we ought to build that wall higher
protect us all from the risks of new
variants pose
and only allow a lower level of
protection
from those relatively few countries
where we can be
very sure that the risks are low have
you made that case to
the prime minister uh certainly made it
to uk
ministers we do now have a weekly
meeting between the first ministers
and uh michael gove as the minister in
charge of the
cabinet office we discuss it there i've
certainly made that point there
and what was the reaction well i i don't
think the uk government's persuaded by
uh what i've suggested uh i've
described previously the approach of the
uk government as
one in which they do the least that they
think that they can get away with
uh rather than the most that is needed
and
we know that those tensions are there
inside the uk cabinet with
some ministers wanting to go further
than the current arrangements
uh i just make the points that i make on
behalf of wales and
on behalf of the approach that we have
always taken which is to be
careful cautious always doing the most
we can to protect people here from this
public health emergency
you say that in wales you're careful and
cautious and always doing the most you
can but on schools you're actually
doing more when it comes to reopening
and easing restrictions and the uk
government is boris johnson says that
nothing's going to happen before the 8th
of march well in wales schools will be
phased in from the 22nd of february
you know the r8 in wells is only just
below one you're worrying that it could
rise above one
when some of those schools and some of
those pupils start returning to the
classroom
well we're able to do this because we
went into a national lockdown here
in wales before christmas and the impact
of that is now being felt very
significantly when we
went into the national lockdown the
numbers in wales of people
per 100 000 contracting coronavirus was
over 650
it's under 100 in wales today positivity
rates are falling the number of people
in hospital with coronavirus is falling
that is what has created
a small amount of headroom for us to
bring the very youngest children back
into school
from the 22nd of february but what we
will do
is then to monitor that very carefully
indeed
because the kent variant which is so
much more aggressive
and can be transmitted so much more uh
easily
we will want to make sure that those
first steps aren't resulting
in the virus getting away from us again
in the r number
rising so these are tentative and first
steps which will be carefully monitored
hopefully of course we hope that uh
things will continue to improve
we want to get children back into school
as fast as it is
safe to do that you say that you're
going to be carefully monitoring things
does that mean you could
actually close primary schools again
then if the data moves in the wrong
direction
yes the advice to us from our chief
medical officer and scientists
is is that you should in the these early
stages
you should always take measures that
could be reversed quickly
if you needed to do that so there were
to be unintended consequences from
having three to seven year olds back
into school
then of course we would be able to go
into reverse now we absolutely don't
want to do that
uh we want to see things continuing to
improve we want this to be the first
step
on the journey to getting more children
back into the classroom
but if things were to uh go against us
if a new variant were to
appear for example then we could
go back to the position we're in today
with no children other than the
vulnerable
and those of key workers currently in
face-to-face education
okay um there have been calls from
labour for teachers to be
prioritized and moved up the vaccine
queue just to try and get schools
reopen that's obviously against the
violence
the advice of the joint committee on
vaccination and immunisation do you
agree or disagree with kirsten there
well we don't take the same view
on that matter we follow the advice of
the jcvi
the jcbi will be considering the case
for professional groups being moved up
the priority list if their advice
changes
our approach will change while their
advice continues to be to focus on the
top
nine priority groups then that is what
we will do
[Music]
do you think that he's ignoring the
science then uh the labour leader by
calling for the advice of the jcvr to be
overridden
well as i understand it what kia osama
has asked is for the case for
uh teachers to be carefully considered
by the jcbi and
which they're doing anyway well i i
believe they are doing that and if they
can be moved up
the priority list then that is what the
jcbi will conclude and that is what we
will do
but as a government here in wales we
have said from the outset
alongside other governments we will
follow the advice of the jcvi
at the moment it isn't to move teachers
to the front
of the queue if and when that changes
then our approach will change alongside
it i just wonder if this is feeds into
what some people's concerns are about
kirsten's handling of the
pandemic who's effectively calling for
the jcbi to consider advice that they're
already considering
is he if you like just calling for
things that are
inevitable and are you concerned at all
about his leadership given the fact
that the conservatives seem to have
received a bit of a bounce in the polls
even if it's short term in response to
the magazine roll out
no i think kirsten has done an excellent
job in holding this government
to account in making sure that they have
to
carefully consider the issues that
matter to people
across the united kingdom including here
in wales
it's our top priority as i don't want to
get children back
into the classroom as safely as we can
and i
completely understand why there is a
debate around whether or not teachers
should
be moved up the queue for vaccination as
i say
we we follow the advice of the jcvi it's
what you have to do
uh as a government but i don't think
that it was wrong
uh of sir kirsten to raise the issue and
i think he has been
extraordinarily effective uh in making
sure that the prime minister
is answerable for the actions that he
takes okay
thank you very much for coming on the
programme this morning much very good
there
thank you
now we've already heard on today's show
that any lockdown easing will be guided
by the data there are still
thousands of cases and hundreds of
deaths every day but things
do seem to be moving in the right
direction now as you can see the
number of daily cases is coming down
fluctuations of course but the blue line
that's the rolling
seven day average has clearly fallen
from the peak around christmas and new
year
so is the virus definitely receding and
what does it mean
for easing restrictions well we can ask
professor
tim specter from king's college at
london uh thank you very much for
uh being with us now your covert symptom
study app lets 4.5 million people report
their symptoms pretty comprehensive
database what is it showing in terms of
the virus and how many cases there are
currently
well the zoe app as we call it
colloquially as
has been showing that since the first of
january
cases have been falling across the
country
and the r value has really been
persistently below one during that time
and so we're now have uh
we've dropped by about 80 percent uh
since that time so
uh it currently means that um
we're at a similar state to where we
were in opt
in october and if we
look at the trajectories of where we're
going
uh in a couple of weeks we're going to
be where we were
at the end of may beginning of june if
people can remember that far back
last year so that means there will be
below
a prevalence which is the number of
people affected
uh have symptomatic covered of less than
one in five hundred
which in my view means that we should be
able to
reduce some of these restrictions and
i'm particularly concerned that we
get kids back to school as long as
possible because of the
known long-term negative effects of that
so
i'm the other the other consideration of
course is what's going on in the nhs and
that's what
people argue as a reason we shouldn't um
you know reduce these restrictions too
quickly and
the data are showing again
about a 60 drop in hospital admissions
and a about 50
drop in the number of percentage of
people who are in hospital with covid
uh since the worst worst of this which
was about the second week of january
so you mentioned looking quite good you
mentioned schools there
and we just spoke to mark drakeford
obviously in wales they are
reopening primary schools at a quicker
rate
than in england the prime minister said
that he hopes
to allow schools to reopen from the 8th
of march do you think it should be done
earlier than that then
um i think it's going to if it was up to
me
i would say there are some regions where
it could be open up earlier
particularly in rural areas where they
have very low rates of
disease and particularly if you focused
on the low risk group
which is the youngest children who
really pose very little risk to
themselves
or other people so
but i think to be honest if we had a
definite date of of the 8th of march
and we stuck to it i think most parents
around the country would be happy
because that would give them time to
prepare as well because
what people don't like is having sudden
switches in policy overnight
which can also uh cause problems yes
definitely when you're trying to kind of
prepare
home learning and obviously the teachers
as well the logistics of it too
um professor neil ferguson told me uh
this week
that we could see low level restrictions
like face mask wearing at
big public gatherings even into next
year do you think that's true or do you
think we could see a complete return to
normal earlier
um my belief is that
it isn't a yes no scenario we're not
going to suddenly wake up one day and
say
uh we're all cured you know like in the
hollywood movies
and uh wave flags
it's going to be a slow decrease out of
this
where we're going to have to need to be
cautious about new variants coming in
uh keeping an eye on how our vaccines
are doing
and so it makes sense to be sensible for
a while longer whilst still
keeping the vast majority of our social
life
and economic life and educational life
going so
i've said before i see a scenario and
it's not necessarily what i want
and i get criticized whenever i mention
scenarios as does neil ferguson
but i can see us uh carrying on
uh using masks in certain situations and
why not have
uh wash your hands when you go to the
supermarket or you're touching food
um these are things that other countries
routinely do if you look at japan
they do wear masks every winter
and it may not be compulsory maybe but i
think
this is the sort of scenario we're going
to see
but i'm also an optimist and i believe
that
we're going to drive the levels of this
virus really low
and the combination of also
the vaccine success and um i want to
come on and
if we can talk about that a bit as well
because our app is also
showing us some very good data on the
vaccine what is the app showing on the
vaccine then
well so we've now got about a third of a
million people have logged their
first dose of a vaccine with us on the
zoe app
and anyone who's listening please if you
had a vaccine do
do log it log with us and we're showing
very low levels of side effects
and we show that after three weeks we're
getting
a 67 um
protection uh against the virus so
like three times less um
risk than you you'd be getting otherwise
compared to uh
unprotected control so that's much
perhaps
a better rate than people have thought
just on a single jab
and so i think that combined with the
data we're seeing
uh is gives me a lot of reason to be
optimistic
that we're going to be in a much better
place in
two to four weeks time and can start to
uh reduce some of these restrictions
that's really encouraging what kind of
sample size is it for
the vaccine data do you know well we've
analyzed about the first 50
000 uh people so it's a large sample and
these
are healthcare workers who are at high
risk so
they're the ones you would see changes
in most and
we're seeing a consistent fall that no
protection at all in the first two weeks
but and that's important for people to
notice because i think people rush out
and think they're cured
and there's high risk of infection then
we are seeing lots of cases
but after two weeks it drops to about 46
percent
and our three weeks to six weeks it's 67
which is really great if that was around
the country
you know uh then we would have really
knocked this uh virus on the head
how do you work out the 67 percent
uh we compare it to a group of control
uh individuals who are healthcare
workers of the same age and sex
who have been logging with us and
haven't had the vaccine
so it's not the same as a a randomized
trial the data is not as clear-cut
but it's a real-life situation and this
often people say that
um the trials so over overestimate the
benefits of vaccines so
this is the first large scale real uh
real-time data we have on on this of a
single jab
so it's still preliminary we're still
analyzing the results every week as
people give us more data
but it's it's just to say that it's
looking very promising and that the
the government's approach of delaying
the second
shot in order to get more people
vaccinated uh
looks like it's paying off now you
are able to report lots of different
symptoms on your
app and at the minute though you're only
many people are only
eligible for a cover test if you display
a cough a fever or a loss of smell and
taste
now my producers always say that i
shouldn't use anything to do my own life
because
anecdotal but i recently had covered and
had none of those three symptoms they
wouldn't have been
eligible uh for a test do you think the
symptom range needs to be expanded and
is there evidence that with the new
variance we're seeing different symptoms
well we've been saying since
last spring that the range of symptoms
should be expanded
and this has been clear from the people
reporting on our app where there are
over 20 symptoms of covid that are
linked and we've done
uh we've published papers and continues
to do research saying the same thing's
happening is that 30 percent of people
who have a positive pcr test uh as
perhaps you did
do not have those three classic symptoms
and
this is particularly true in the first
three days of the illness
when uh it's most infectious so
i understand why we didn't do this last
spring because we didn't have any
testing
and it would have uh crashed the system
now we have a fantastic testing system
able to do over 600 000 tests a day
we do have the capacity to do it this is
the time to do that and we would reduce
uh infections by 30 percent in reality
because
these people would be told to stay at
home at the moment
it's you know it's a real risk that we
are ignoring
and all these smoke screens of testing
asymptomatic people
is far less productive than getting to
these people that
actually have symptoms and are spreading
the virus around so absolutely um
and i've forgotten your other question
that was it i think that's all good
oh i did ask if the new variant uh leads
to different symptoms
it's interesting that the the jury's out
on this
the the ons uh survey which is a similar
size to us but very different
methodology
showed that there was more evidence of
headaches and fatigue
and um sore throats
whereas our data which has been
consistent since since the beginning
has shown no difference so i i think we
don't know yet
i think we need to keep a close eye on
it but if everyone was more aware
that you know the two common symptoms of
early covid
are headache and fatigue and sort and
then you've got sore throat and sore
muscles
then actually everyone would be safer so
i think it's it's a good debate to keep
going on and keep looking at
now you said recently that you don't
watch the number 10 news conferences
anymore
why not um
well i i i've overdone on covert stats i
guess
and i also um i i also
get a bit disheartened by the fact that
we only focus on certain of those
statistics so
uh the fact that not just the number 10
but also the media
focus on the number of deaths that day
and i think it's a very misleading
statistic
because um i can't know whether
it's very sad people die uh of anything
but for example yesterday around 600
people died of covid
but uh on a normal
day in february 1500 people would die
mostly of heart disease strokes
um cancer etc so or
the flu so we never put those statistics
into any uh context and i think
this has got a lot of people extremely
anxious um
and you know are petrified to leave
their homes and may have real problems
coming out again if we don't put these
stats
into some real perspective that yes
rates are high people are dying from
covid but they also die from other
things
many of those people are not seeking
help in the nhs
they are having mental health problems
uh they're not getting their cancer
looked at
not looking after their heart etc so i
just would like to see
also uh perhaps less
fear-mongering and more a general
picture and that's
oh we've just lost you um we did get uh
through most of the interview though uh
fascinating stuff professor
tim spector there uh from kings the
founder of the zoe app
now we were talking about schools a lot
on the program with dominic raff with
mark drakeford and also of course with
professor spectre as well
the damage being done to children their
education and mental health by being out
of the classroom
is something that of course looks set to
continue for at least a few more weeks
in england now someone who wants to see
more done to address this is anne
longfield who's stepping down as
children's commissioner next month
and she joins us now thank you for being
on the programme
good morning um we're just hearing that
some quite positive data from
the zoe app but also from the official
case data as well
that case numbers do seem to be coming
down do you think that schools could
reopen sooner than the 8th of march in
england
well i certainly hope they can open as
soon as possible especially primary
schools
and i think parents and indeed children
have their eyes on what is going to be
said at the press conference
in a few days time in terms of a road
map but also
whether their school will be opening on
the 8th
you know we should remember that most
kids have been out of school
for just about a year they've just had a
few weeks back
in and of course during that time most
have been falling behind in their
education
they've been away from their friends and
away from those support networks that
are just so important to them
especially those that are more
vulnerable
you said especially primary schools at
the beginning of your answer do you
think there is a case
to allow younger pupils to return before
secondary schools
well that's certainly something that um
countries across europe have been doing
um i mean the case is that those
children are less able to work at home
remotely
uh their their parents need to be there
um
because they need a greater level of
care and support to learn
and they're much less likely to pick up
that level of infection
or indeed potentially transmit
so across europe you've got france
you've got italy you've got spain
all of whom have primary schools now
back open now of course there's
exam years as well that we need to look
at for older children
but certainly for primaries this seems
to be a trend that actually smaller
entities
can get back open and can be managed
of course catching up on a year of
disrupted education
is going to be really very difficult and
what's it going to require
and do you think we should look at
things like shortening the school
holiday for example to give a bit more
time
it's going to take a huge effort uh
really this
is kind of a war effort kind of scale
um there needs of course to be a boost
for children uh
in terms of catch up in education terms
in the classroom
potentially as well using some of those
times
yes in school holidays the longer day
but part of that
really needs to be as well about helping
children to build back those
social skills and that confidence you
know they haven't been in school
but they haven't been going to their
football classes either they haven't
been going to their karate classes so
all the
fabric of children's lives have
disappeared over
the last year so we need to see a really
ambitious program of recovery
with you know significant investment now
i think
from government i've always said
children haven't had their
nightingale moment yet and this is the
time because i think
the alternative is that there's a group
of children who won't
make up the time they've lost these are
the ones who started behind
who are struggling potentially about one
in six children
if they don't get that level of support
and boost they won't ever catch up
during their time at school and that's
something that
they and all of us will um you know root
the benefits um
or or see the um see the impact of
yeah one in six children maybe not ever
catching up is really quite alarming
and i was also interested what you say
about the mental health aspect too
because it feels that we're very good at
picking apart the academic impact of
what the last year has been
but as you say there are social impacts
as well
children spending all day looking at
screens young children in particular
being told that they should be fearful
of close contact with other people
what do you think the consequences of
this could be well we already had a
significant mental health
problem for most children in this
country from many children this country
simon stephens called it an epidemic
only two years ago
but what we've had over the last year is
really you know the shock
of the pandemic but also that lack of
interaction with others
which at different ages has its impact
for very young children
i've had parents talk to me about how
their children have been come
clingy shy to talk to other children not
able to talk to other
children in the park for primary
school-aged children
actually a third of children told me
last summer that they were
worried about what the future would
bring you know all of the things they
expected to be around them and to be
stable in their lives have suddenly gone
and then of course
you know those that are in secondary
school and have their focus on exams and
what comes next
there are terrific number of uh
uncertainties for those children so we
know the prevalence again is one in six
for those children as well in terms of
probable mental health conditions i'd
like to see
mental health teams in and around every
school to really help children
at the first instance before it falls
into crisis
education secretary gavin williamson's
had a lot of criticism about the way
that he's handled
the pandemic what do you make of his
performance
well look i have left who sits around
the cabinet table very much the prime
minister
and of course it's been a difficult year
with a lot
um to cope with but i don't need to tell
you that they have been
difficulties over the last year and
schools themselves will be the first to
say that
i'm pleased that the prime minister is
taking a lead on this
i'm pleased that the emphasis now and
that commitment is
to put children and put in schools at
the heart of the
opening up of uh the economy and opening
up of the country
and i think that's where it needs to be
because it's much more complex than just
what goes on in schools
a whole range of factors need to be in
place to ensure that schools open
and that now must be the priority just
finally research by the joseph rowntree
foundation this week has found that over
four million children
are living in poverty in the uk over one
million of them
under the age of five given this would
you like to see the 20 pound a week
uplift to universal credit extended
yes i think it does need to be extended
it's had an important impact and that
needs to continue
this isn't the time for families to have
that uncertainty
or that drop in income and what we do
know with very young children that
clearly
are bearing some of the branch of that
increase in poverty
if you fall behind before you get to
school you have very
few chances to catch up during your
school day so the impact of
those early years can have a huge impact
on a child's life throughout
so it is so important i think it's clear
now we have a problem with poverty in
this country
we really need a long-term plan as part
of that buildback
to ensure that all children can flourish
and all cam families can give their
children
the support they want to okay anne
longfield thank you so much for
coming on the program this morning thank
you
before we move on a reminder do check
out the safer ridge on sunday podcast it
features the best bits of our interviews
each week plus analysis from me and my
producer matt aveda
it's available from lunchtime on the sky
news app spotify and
apple podcast so do check that out
now labour is today calling for the debt
built up by businesses during the
pandemic to be treated like
student debt now to talk about that and
more we're joined by the shadow
chief secretary bridget phillipson i'm
keen to talk about your business plan
uh but first if i may i'm keen to start
on schools we're just talking to anne
longfield there about the impact
on children that the pandemic has had
the government wants schools to return
from march the 8th does that mean to be
all schools or would you be happy if
primary schools for example
or schools in some regions when it went
in first
well the government does need to be very
much guided by all of the science and
the data that's made available to them
but absolutely schools should be the
first to open which should be a real
priority for the government
to make sure that our children can get
back to school and all parents will have
seen the impact that being out of school
for many children or the disruption to
education
that's been caused particularly for the
most vulnerable children
you know the fact that children can't
play with their friends in the same way
anymore
you know the educational impact has been
severe but yes we do absolutely need to
see children all children back in school
as quickly as possible
that just does need to be done safely
say that all children should be back in
school as quickly as possible that it
should be done safely i mean that is
exactly what we'd hear from
dominic rob a few moments ago as well
should all schools
and all year groups go back at the same
time or would you be happy to see a
staggered approach
well the government does need to
consider the advice that they receive
and it may be necessary
to stagger that but we will work with
the government to make sure that it's
done in a careful considered way
but we do also need to see a much
clearer plan set out from the government
around supporting children to catch up
on the misleading that they've had to
experience
but also making sure as you heard just
earlier from the children's commissioner
that we look at all of the impacts on
children's well-being overall because
you know it has been a really difficult
time children have lost out such a great
deal
but we do need to make sure that when
they go back it's as safe as possible
so if the scientific advice is that it
would be safer to for example allow
younger children to
return first or to allow some year
groups like those taking exams to return
first you'd be happy with that
we'll look at what the government says
but of course we the government should
be guided
by the data from the science it's
available and we look carefully at what
they set out it should be done
in a measured way i think parents and
teaching staff will understand it has to
be done
carefully and following the best
possible advice okay now we understand
that labour
wants to allow businesses who have built
up debt during the pandemic i'm sure a
lot of businesses that applies to
for that to be treated like student debt
just explain
the idea to us we know that so many
businesses have had a really really
tough year i've heard from so many of
them
that they're really starting to find
that debt mountain they've built up hard
to deal with
and they need breathing space to get
through this crisis so we don't believe
that businesses should be paying back
money that they've needed to borrow
until they're in a much stronger
position and until they're growing again
we know that in this country we've had
the worst economic crisis of any major
economy
and as right now going into the next
months ahead
850 000 businesses are at risk and that
puts two and a half million jobs on the
line
we need to see urgent action from the
government now to deal with that they
can't wait
until the budget they need urgent action
from the chancellor
to help them get through this time some
businesses of course
may never be able to pay off the amount
of debt that they have built up
during this unbelievable year so under
your plan
could that debt be written off and
effectively covered by the taxpayer in
the same way
that it is with student loans
well it's more likely that that some of
that debt will be written off if we
don't take action now because
businesses many of them particularly
smaller businesses are just drowning
under this debt and they need to see
real concerted action from the
government
of course some businesses are in a
stronger position particularly some of
those
larger businesses and we take a
different approach there but you know
what we've been listening to business we
know that they'll be driving
the recovery that we need to see the
growth that we need to see in job
creation
so we need to be working with them to
make sure that the solutions that we put
in place
don't see good businesses going bust
because of short-term decision making
so it could it could be written off as
the answer
well unless we take action debt will be
written off that's that's for sure
so putting in place a plan that allows
businesses to deal with this in a formal
manageable way
would be a responsible way to be
approaching this businesses just don't
understand why the chancellor hasn't got
to grips
with the crisis that they're facing he
isn't listening we also need to see i
believe
a smart furlough introduced to support
businesses to get through this
we also believe that the extension of
the business rates holiday should
continue
but also to see that further extension
of the vat cut
you know so many businesses have found
this a real struggle over the course of
the last year
and if they go bust it will make our
recovery so much harder
okay of course all these plans will
cost money or take money as well we've
seen the worst fall in gdp
since the invention of gdp this week and
many would like to see the chancellor
start to
rebalance the books if you like when he
has
gives the budget in march now kirsten
said this week that over the course of
the recovery
tax rises are not the right way to go
so are there any tax risers that rishi
sooner could propose in the budget that
you would support
you'll struggle to find an economic
expert who believes that right now we
should be raising taxes
on families whereas in fact the
chancellor is doing precisely that
with his council tax hit if we pressed
ahead with tax rises now that would pull
demand
out of our economy it would mean that
families have got less money to spend
in our shops and high streets and it
would damage the recovery that i think
we all want to see
you know we are at a fork in the road
now we want to see britain come back
strongly and to emerge from this
terrible terrible pandemic that we've
experienced
but if the chancellor presses ahead with
tax rises not only will it hurt families
but it will be economically illiterate
and as i say you'd struggle to find
anybody right now
who's saying that tax rises on families
the right way to be going about this
i'm not talking about tax prices on
families specifically are there any tax
risers that rishi sunet could propose
that labour would support
now absolutely isn't the time to
pressing ahead with tax tax rises that
is an approach that we would support
okay thank you now i just want to talk
to you a little bit about
labor 116 000 people have now died after
testing positive for covid we've seen
the biggest economic hit since the great
frost in 1709.
and yet the conservatives have actually
managed to extend
the poll lead over labour their leave
leading labour in the polls
lots of people will be looking at that
thinking why isn't labour doing better
in the circumstances
well a little over a year ago we
suffered one of the worst general
election defeats
in our history so we always knew that it
was going to take a long time
to regain the trust of the british
people once more but i think we've made
tremendous progress over the course
of that time under kia stammer's new
leadership if you'd said to me
in december 2019 that we would have made
the progress we've made
already i would have taken off your
right arm to have been uh
making such fantastic progress but of
course you know after such a terrible
defeat it will take time
to regain the trust of the british
people once more we've always been clear
about that
but at the same time i think there is an
expectation from the british people
that we're constructive in the
opposition that we put to the government
this is a crisis like no other so we
have pushed the government and given
voice to the concerns that we've had not
least on the economic recovery
where because we've had the worst
economic crisis of any major economy
we face a very difficult path back and
that's because going into this crisis
the country was built on weak economic
foundations but you know we're making
great progress of course
of course it's a party there is more to
do okay and some on the left of the
party are getting
a little bit jittery uh people like john
mcdonnell at the unite
union wanting to see a june emergency
conference to try and address some of
their concerns
now those on the left i guess would like
you to take a few more risks to call for
things that aren't just going to happen
anyway to differentiate
between labor and the government is the
problem that labour at the minute is
just a bit boring
well you know we're years out for an
election so of course we'll set out very
detailed
policy that rises to the challenge that
britain faces at that point
but we are in the middle of a pandemic
after all and we absolutely have to be
focused
on getting the country through this
crisis but we have made tremendous
progress as a party but you know when i
think back to that terrible election
defeat
in december 2019 the first priority for
us as a party had to be
earning the right to be heard once more
by the british people we've done that
i think kia stammer has demonstrated
that he is a prime minister
next prime minister for this country
he's ready to do that job and there is
genuine and real
enthusiasm from people that i speak to
about the progress that labour
has made of course there is still much
more that we need to do we always knew
it would be a tough road ahead
okay thank you for coming on the show it
looks very picturesque and snowy where
you are but
bit chilly as well so i hope you've got
a nice cup of tea somewhere standing by
and thank you for being on thank you
thanks well that's it for a pretty busy
show don't go anywhere after the break
i'll be joined by our political
correspondent rob powell to go through
everything we learned
in sophie reach the take and do check
out the podcast too available in all the
usual places from lunchtime today
see you after this short break
[Music]
you